Speaker 1: Hey, this is really interesting.
Conspiracy theorist Alex Jones appears not
only to have completely turned on Donald Trump
at this point, but seems to be lining up behind
Ron DeSantis now.
Little bits and pieces of this we've picked
up over the last couple of months.
There was a story from a couple of months
ago where over vaccines Alex Jones seemed
to have turned on Donald Trump.
Recently, I believe during an interview with
Marjorie Taylor Greene, Alex Jones said something
about a decent is green presidential ticket.
But now Alex Jones, straight up, is saying
DeSantis is better than Trump.
Let's take a listen to this.
This was from a recent episode of Infowars.
Speaker 2: I've gone from liking DeSantis
to loving DeSantis to my instinct have told
me he's good and now he's he's he's he's he's
got my full backing.
While he's the real deal, he's better than
Trump.
I'm not try to pick favorites here, I want
Trump to get jealous and become more like
the Santas.
We all need to be more like the Santas.
He's a gentleman, he's smart, he's a family
man, he's a patriot, he's a veteran, he is
our leader.
I mean, if you know about who's leading the
fight against the new world order, it's Tucker
Carlson and two Santas.
Speaker 1: This is a major, I mean, for Alex
Jones to declare someone else his leader.
I know it's very easy to laugh all of this
stuff off and go Alex Jones, who's a.
It is actually it's horrifying, but it actually,
Matt, there is a movement here, and when they
declare a leader, it actually matters
Speaker 2: for classy men that are gentlemen
that really caught everybody that I would
say are the best examples of leadership in
America to Santos and Tucker Carlson.
I'm obviously the shock trooper that, you
know, is, is the crack in your release and
I'm and I'm proud to be that.
But I can tell you that my job has been to
expose this and bring in the man and bring
in the women.
I use kind of John the Baptist analogy.
I've God told me that God, like
Speaker 1: Alex Jones, is John the Baptist
now.
I mean, look at how sick this is.
But but again, if they are getting behind
the Santas, it actually does matter.
Speaker 2: You are going to launch the attack.
You are going to prepare the ground.
Your people are the ground and then you watch
the leaders will rise.
And we're and we're seeing that in all of
us are rising, ladies and gentlemen.
But I just give credit where it's due.
It's people like the Santas and people like
their girls.
And I've almost got Rogen super hardcore.
He's almost there.
I know he's super hard.
Speaker 1: I don't know if that's true, by
the way, that he almost has rogue.
And maybe it is.
Maybe it isn't
Speaker 2: or in any kind of goes back a little.
But I just got to spend more time with him.
I love Joe.
We can hang on.
I want to get my call.
Let's go get dinner and hang out some of the
like twice a week.
I just, you know, you just Joe is really such
a sweetheart.
But he doesn't want to be in the middle of
a fight.
Not that he's a coward.
He's almost embarrassed to be that deep in
the fight.
And it's OK.
Speaker 1: So Alex Jones here making it clear
that DeSantis is their leader.
Interestingly enough, when you look at the
money line, when you because you you one of
the great things about America, great or terrible,
you can bet on anything you want and people
bet on who is the Republican nominee going
to be.
And it has not shifted significantly.
If you go to predict it, dawg, you can look
at the betting markets on a lot of these different
questions and the question who will win the
2024 Republican nomination?
It's pretty steady.
But DeSantis is a very close to Trump.
Trump, about 38 cents of every dollar is being
bet on.
Trump will be the nominee, and twenty nine
cents of every dollar is being bet on Ron
DeSantis is going to be the nominee.
So this is, let's put it this way.
This margin for Trump right now in terms of
who people believe will be the nominee for
the Republicans in 2024.
This is one scandal away from reversing.
If Trump has some major scandal, that's really
embarrassing among the Republicans and of
course, his his most devoted followers don't
care about if it's something that people who
are still slightly connected to reality are
turned off by that nine point.
You know, that's a four and a half point swing,
right?
In the sense that if Trump loses four and
a half and DeSantis gains four and a half,
you've got a tie for the Republican nomination.
Those are precarious numbers for Donald Trump,
given that we are two and a half roughly years
out from the 2024 election.
So it's a race to the bottom, believe me,
but it's a race to the bottom that we care
about because the consequences are unimaginably
huge.
Huge.
As I talked about earlier, Republicans winning
elections in the next two election cycles
imperils American democracy.
And so that's why we care whether Alex Jones
is abandoning Trump or not, and he does indeed
seem to be.
Let me know your thoughts.
Let me know your thoughts about who you believe
will be the Republican nominee if it's something
you're already thinking about.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
It is April 1st and it is great to be here.
And we've got a packed program for you coming
up today.
The David Pakman Show is a viewer and listener
supported program, you can sign up and get
a membership at join Packman dot com.
You can also now gift memberships if you have
one, but you want to give one to someone else.
You can check the this is a gift box in the
sign up process and if you don't have anyone
to give a membership to.
We have 220 people who have requested free
memberships.
We will be glad to give you to give them one
of the memberships that you gift.
You can do it all at join Pacman dot com.
Let's hear from people in the audience.
We do these calls once a week via Discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord, and
it is a great thing.
It's a shame we can't do it more.
I would say much to the chagrin of many in
our audience.
Let's start today.
Oh, I don't know.
Let's go to Canada.
Let's start with Jason from Toronto.
Hey, Dave, how are you doing?
I'm doing well, thank you for asking.
Speaker 3: Thanks for taking my call again.
I actually spoke to you recently about Putin
and Russia and the impact that that would
have with Trump in power.
So thanks for taking my call again.
Just a quick question.
Not really political or politics related,
but more.
Just a personal question.
What do you enjoy most about what you do?
Speaker 1: Honestly, it's that I it's not
really a real job in the sense of like, I
don't have an annoying boss or have to go
anywhere or anything like that.
It's just the autonomy, I would say.
Speaker 3: Awesome.
I know that you've been doing this for a while
now.
How many years have you been had your show?
Speaker 1: I think about 80 years now.
Speaker 3: That's awesome.
Well, anyways, thanks for taking my call.
It was just a simple question, right?
Speaker 1: And things are good in Canada.
Speaker 3: Yeah, things are things are good.
We still have a little bit of snow here in
southern Ontario, which is really annoying,
but I'll be in the states in a couple of weeks.
So I'm kind of excited to go somewhere warmer
is.
Speaker 1: Is Ontario hostile to poutine because
it's just too French?
Speaker 3: Oh, no, it's just less prevalent
around here, but people embrace the food just
as they would in Montreal or across Canada,
so
Speaker 1: that's good news.
I'm pleased by that, at least for sure.
All right, thank you for the call.
Great to talk to you.
Take care.
All right, there is Jason from Toronto.
What a day.